hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his book of moral theory the right in
the good chapter 2wd Ross talks about
seven prima facia duties and the seventh
of these perhaps in some respects the
most important is the duty of what he
calls non-maleficence that's kind of a
mouthful the nun of course means not and
Maleficent's means not doing that
maleficents means doing harm to another
so now i Maleficent's means not doing
harm to another and we could say the
same thing about the duty of beneficence
and it's a relationship to benevolence
as we can about Maleficent's in relation
to malevolence in the case of the Voland
PSA's what we're talking about is an
intention and inclination a wish
choosing and Ross says well that's
that's good that's important to focus on
but what I'm really interested in as far
as duties go is what people actually do
so it's not just our duty to not want to
harm people or to not intend to harm
them it's our duty not to actually harm
them that's the primary duty they
talks about in this and it's interesting
because he says look this is the only
one that's actually being pitched in a
negative manner and if you look at
historical codes of morality or even law
what you'll find is that many of the
particular precepts they actually have
to do with non-maleficence so for
example the Decalogue the Ten
Commandments thou shalt not steal
stealing is harming another person in
terms of their property you're taking
something that doesn't belong to you
thou shalt not kill you're taking
somebody's life that's been very clear
type of harm thou shalt not bear false
witness which typically has been
interpreted as not lying yeah not only
does that one have to do with fidelity
as Ross says but you can also be harming
somebody by saying false things about
them thou shalt not commit adultery it's
interesting in ancient times adultery
was not just seen as something that
harmed the person who was being cheated
upon it was seen as harming a whole
bunch of different people including the
children who are the progeny of it
because you might not be able to know
whose parents of the mother they
actually belong to so it was it was seen
in terms of harm in a lot of different
ways and if you look at historical codes
of morality oftentimes in terms of
religion but also in terms of of you
know secular legal codes you can see
that this principle of not harming
others is given a very very high
priority and Ross says that it really
should be given the highest priority of
all it has the greatest amount of what
he calls stringency that doesn't mean
that in every single case not harming
others is going to take priority over
every other duty every other prima Fache
of duty
but it means that in general it's going
to have a very high priority and you're
gonna have to make some sort of case why
that duty that prima facie duty of not
harming should be superseded in that
case Ross says that this is a duty in
general that means that we owe it to
everybody not to harm and now to allow
to be harmed so this you know within
reason of course this covers a lot of
ground it's not it's not enough for me
just not to actively harm people if I
can prevent them from being injured by
something that I know is going to happen
Ross would say I actually have a duty to
make sure that they aren't going to be
harmed in that case some people want to
say well you could really sum that up as
just being sort of the flipside of the
duty of beneficence the duty of the
nificent says that I want to act in such
a way as to improve other people's
conditions with respect to pleasure or
pain moral virtue or intelligence and
Ross says no it's not just the flipside
of beneficence here you would be varying
from say the utilitarians it's something
that we recognize as a principle in its
own right it's not just that I'm not
gonna use a lot of negatives here it's
just it's not that I'm not to keep from
helping somebody it's that I'm not to
harm them and harming is something
different
Ross would say and distinct from just
not helping so it's not going to be just
a flip side or mirror of beneficence it
is the most stringent like I pointed out
of the duties and it derives from the
fact of the vulnerability of others and
the many different ways in which we are
actually vulnerable to each other
Ross doesn't dwell on
but perhaps one way of thinking about
this that might actually have to do with
what we call empathy or compassion we
can look at our own vulnerabilities we
can say to a child who harms another
child or to an adult who's acting like a
jerk who's acting childishly what would
it feel like for you if somebody did
that to you would it bother you if so
then why are you doing it to another
person do you have some some compelling
overarching reason you know deriving
from some other duty justice fidelity
gratitude reparation something like that
that would override this particular Duty
that's one way to think about this
another way is just to be you know
attune to the fact that others can be
harmed by our actions or our in actions
by our habits by our ways of of
comporting ourselves towards them and
again Ross doesn't spell this out but I
think it's very useful to think in terms
of his you know the goods that he
describes and comes back to over and
over again the intrinsic goods pleasure
or the flipside pain moral virtue and
intelligence if I'm hurting somebody
physically mentally even in terms of the
things that that you know are just
instrumental Goods if I'm destroying
their income if I'm destroying their
reputation
I am violating this duty of
non-maleficence and I'd better have some
really good reason or I'm doing the
wrong thing and insofar as I'm harming
them I probably am still incurring a
subsequent duty of reparation even if I
can say look my duty to another person
to keep my promise is gonna require me
to actually allow somebody to be hurt I
probably should make it up to that other
person that I have a duty to them
pleasure and pain is pretty easy to
think in in terms
what about intelligence if I'm spreading
misinformation whether I realize it or
not I'm actually harming other people if
I'm making other people dumber we could
think of you know certain television
shows or advertisements or policies that
people have is actually being
large-scale violations of the duty of
non-maleficence if we're making people
worse off with respect to their
intellectual faculties
we're actually harming them likewise
when it comes to moral virtue if I am
making people worse off with respect to
the kind of character that they have the
kind of person that they they have you
know if for example I am taking an
alcoholic who's recovering out for
drinks I can say well you know it's
dirty so I didn't really hurt them I'm
placing temptation in their path I'm
violating my duty to to non-maleficence
I'm not just not being benevolent to
them I'm actually harming them setting
them up to get hurt in the process if I
tempt people in other ways that will
make them a worse person if I if I have
a position of authority and I I behave
in a poor manner that that provides a
bad role model to other people that
provides a scandal a stumbling block as
we say Ross would say I'm actually
violating the duty of non-maleficence so
insofar as we make other people better
off with respect to morality we are
following the duty of beneficence
insofar as we make other people worse in
the world terms whatever contribution we
make we may be making in that respect we
are violating the duty of
non-maleficence now another thing that
Ross says it's also very interesting and
important to keep in mind he says I am
concerned about people's attitude
whose mind sets inclinations motives but
I'm not concerned about that primarily
what I'm concerned about primarily is
actually behaving in a certain manner so
that's why it's not non malevolence not
wishing bad to another person not
intending harm to another person not
having the sort of inclinations that are
going to lead to harm to other people
but rather non-maleficence not actually
doing harm to other people but Ross says
I could have a secondary duty with
respect to my inclinations so for
example if I have an inclination to harm
certain people and that inclination is
going to actually lead me in many cases
to harm people let's say I'm a sadist
Ross would say I have a duty to stop
being a sadist or at least to find some
way to short-circuit that you know very
interesting example of this not not so
much in terms of sadism but in terms of
killing would be the code in the
television show actually cable show
Dexter the father realizes that that his
young adopted son Dexter Morgan is going
to become a serial killer so he teaches
him a code which requires him to
actually demonstrate to himself the
guilt of the person who he's killing and
he becomes a serial killer who preys
upon other serial killers and thereby is
in some way making things better that
would be a sort of governing of
inclinations a you know reorienting
inclinations it's very interesting
because he struggles with this quite a
bit
over the course of the series some of
our inclinations could be sadistic
towards hurting other people we also
have been clinicians that can lead to
our harming others that are not directly
about
but more about ignoring them and
ignoring the vulnerability that they
have to our actions through selfishness
so you know some of our inclinations can
be very strong inclinations to further
our position - you know obtain pleasures
that we want to avoid pains that we
don't want and if we're too selfish
about this and we don't look at how our
actions affect other people then we may
in fact violate this duty of
non-maleficence bike by doing things
that actually harm them so Ross would
say look if you realize that you have
such an inclination such a selfish Drive
then you actually have a duty a
secondary duty to do something about it
and there's a lot of different things
that we could do about that I'm not
going to go into those right now but
those are just secondary duties the
primary duty is not to harm other people
the other duties that have to do with
attitude or assumptions or mindset or
habits or all that sort of stuff those
come out of that those flow out of that